[Musik]
nachrichten des tages
mit mitri sirin
freitagabend um 7 ihnen allen ein
herzliches willkommen die tägliche dosis
sport hat heute wieder kristin otto in
15 minuten guten abend schauen wir uns
gemeinsam den überblick
impfpflicht im gesundheitswesen
bundestag und bundesrat billigen
änderungen am infektionsschutzgesetz
élysée palast und eu der neue kanzler
scholz absolviert antrittsbesuche in
paris und brüssel
und überraschungserfolg beim biathlon
johannes kühn feiert den ersten
weltcupsieg seiner karriere
alle die sich in deutschland härtere
corona maßnahmen wünschen dürften die
heutige entscheidungen von bundestag und
bundesländer begrüßen das
infektionsschutzgesetz wurde noch einmal
nachgeschärft und das bedeutet
beschäftigte im gesundheits- und
pflegeeinrichtungen müssen ab mitte märz
2022 geimpft sein impfen dürfen jetzt
auch zahnärzte tierärzte und apotheker
und die länder bekommen wieder die
möglichkeit gastronomie kultur und
freizeitbetriebe zu schließen heike
slansky hat die neuesten informationen
aus berlin es ist seine erste rede als
bundesgesundheitsminister im hohen haus
da muss er das in windeseile
nachgeschärfte erste ampel gesetz
bereits rechtfertigen nicht ohne
seitenhiebe auf die kritiker es kommt
nicht darauf an dass wir hier einen
überbietungswettbewerb von immer
schärferen maßnahmen fordern die wir
dann wieder einsetzen wie wir dann
wieder einsetzen noch kontrollieren vor
allem die union bestand auf den
nachgebesserten
instrumentenkasten gaststätte freizeit
oder kultureinrichtungen könnten nun
wieder bei bedarf geschlossen werden
doch pauschale schließungen von schulen
oder geschäften soll es nicht mehr geben
sie haben sich selbst des instrumenten
kann beraubt mit dem die bundesländer
zielgenau und effektiv hätten handeln
können was vor der bundestagswahl ein
tabu war und kategorisch ausgeschlossen
wurde ist nun im eilverfahren
beschlossen worden eine teil impfpflicht
für das personal in kranken- und
pflegeeinrichtungen
ab mitte märz die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht gibt der gesamt
freiheitsplatz einen positiven effekt
nämlich den dass wir die gefährdung der
wohngruppen endlich in den griff
bekommen ein finanzieller bonus für
pflegekräfte wurde dagegen aufs neue
jahr fahrtag monieren afd und die linke
ist deutlich zu machen ein grundrecht
relevanter eingriff im all verfahren ist
möglich aber kein minimal ist dankeschön
für die pflegekräfte ist es peinlich
meine damen und herren wir fordern in
diesem zusammenhang zum beispiel eine
finanzielle besserstellung der
pflegeberufe von 1000 euro monatlich für
das verschärfte infektionsschutzgesetz
stimmte mit den ampel parteien auch die
union obwohl sie mehr wollte kurz danach
nahm es der bundesrat in einer
sondersitzung einstimmig an
mit der jetzt beschlossenen impfpflicht
für das gesundheitspersonal ist es so
eine sache viele in den betroffenen
heimen und kliniken sind zwar dafür
finden es aber gleichzeitig ungerecht
dass erst einmal nur sie betroffen sein
sollen und was wenn noch mehr
pflegerinnen und pfleger ihren job
hinschmeißen wo es ja eh zu viel arbeit
für zu wenig beschäftigte gibt mehr von
andreas weise kaffee und bratäpfel für
die seniorinnen auch das alltag für die
pflegekräfte der pfeifferschen
stiftungen in magdeburg
die angestellten hier werden jeden tag
getestet egal ob geimpft oder nicht dass
sie zuerst einer impfpflicht unterliegen
sollen der bereichsleiter der senioren
stifter christian rausch findet das
unfair wir haben eine impfquote unter
den mitarbeitenden von ungefähr 90 in
manchen häusern sogar 95 prozent
und unsere mitarbeiter finden dass das
ein falsches signal ist was da mit
ausgesendet wird wenn nun gerade die
mitarbeiter im gesundheitswesen in den
pflegeeinrichtungen
zuerst eine impfpflicht gekommen der
politik geht es dabei aber vor allem um
die die bisher aus welchem grund auch
immer nicht bereit zum impfen sind wir
haben sehr lange freiwillig versucht mit
vier kommunikation auch viele fake news
an die seite kommt das ist wirklich das
impfen wirklich das wichtigste mittel
ist und deswegen stehe ich jetzt auch so
der impfpflicht stichtag 15 märz 22 wer
dann nicht geimpft ist oder einer test
hat auf die einrichtungen nicht mehr
betreten das ergebnis noch weniger
pflegekräfte so die befürchtung von
verdi wir haben jetzt schon eine flucht
aus den berufen und ehrlich gesagt wenn
da jetzt noch ein paar zusätzlich aus
den berufen raus getrieben werden dann
muss man sich tatsächlich sorgen machen
um die versorgung gerade auch in der
altenpflege der kampf gegen die pandemie
eine gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
findet die vorsteherin der pfeifferschen
stiftungen in magdeburg
wenn wir wollen das zerbrechliche
menschen geschützt sind wohl der abele
gruppen dann ist es nötig dass sich alle
menschen die sich impfen lassen können
auch impfen lassen also wenn eine
impfpflicht dann eine allgemeine
impfpflicht doch ob die irgendwann kommt
darüber wird es noch viele diskussionen
geben
für schulkinder gehören atemmasken in
diesem infektion zu inter zum alltag und
dazu gibt es ein interessantes
testergebnis ffp zwei modelle sind für
sie kaum geeignet 15 masken hat die
stiftung warentest untersucht bei allen
sei der atem widerstand zu groß für das
lungenvolumen von kindern gewesen die
bessere wahl für schüler seien daher op
masken empfehlen die tester auch bei
langen tragen würden den kindern damit
keine schäden drohen
schauen wir jetzt auch die aktuelle lage
in deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet 61
1288 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind rund 13.000 weniger als
vergangenen freitag 4 184 menschen
starben innerhalb eines tages und die
sieben tage incident sinkt nun auf vier
113,7
paris und brüssel das waren heute die
ersten ziele im ausland für
bundeskanzler scholz hier wie dort gibt
große erwartungen an ihn vieles was sich
frankreichs präsident makro und
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
wünschen ließ er sich nämlich nur
umsetzen wenn auch deutschland als
mächtigstes eu-land mit zieht auch der
umgang mit russland und china spielten
eine rolle mehr erfahren wir jetzt von
florian a
ein foto draußen ohne maske dafür sollte
die zeit noch reichen bevor der neue
deutsche bundeskanzler und sein erster
gastgeber an diesem tag der französische
präsident sich um die krisen der welt
kümmern gemeinsam wie sie später
dutzendfach betonen und konflikte
untereinander lieber klein reden etwa
dem streit über schuldenregeln in der
eurozone die frankreich anders als
deutschland dringend reformieren will
nun dürfen wir müssen da mechanismen
finden entweder flexibilität oder neue
regeln die uns erlauben unsere ziele zu
erreichen
scholz antwortet diplomatisch dennoch
bestimmt wachsen und schuldengrenzen
einhalten das würde funktionieren
es ist möglich beides gleichzeitig zu
erreichen und keinen gegensatz das ist
das was uns soweit ich das verstehe auch
ein
nächste station brüssel im schneeregen
da treffen sich zwei die mal gemeinsam
als minister im kabinett merkel saßen
und heute in neuer funktion über einen
möglichen russischen angriff auf die
ukraine sprechen es ist ganz klar dass
deutschland die europäische union und
viele andere
darauf reagieren würden wenn es zu
grenzverletzung kommt aggressionen muss
ein preisschild haben und deshalb werden
wir diese punkte
vorweg in angemessener form mit russland
oder nach russland kommunizieren welche
sanktionen sie damit meinen etwa auch
dem stopp der gaspipeline nord stream 2
das sagen sie heute nicht zumindest
nicht öffentlich
auf seiner ersten auslandsreise bleibt
scholz im ungefähren
erste auslandsreise des neuen
bundeskanzlers theo koll sie begleiten
olaf scholz welchen eindruck hat er
hinterlassen
also der eindruck ist hier von extrem
viel kontinuität der ist sehr leise
aufgetreten fast merkel ist an einer
stelle hat er sogar davon gesprochen die
kanzlerin habe dies oder das entschieden
also da ist ja noch nicht so ganz in
seiner rolle angekommen als kanzler er
ist oft erkennbar im ungefähren
geblieben als makro gefordert hat im
rahmen der europa visionen man müsse die
schuldengrenze auf weichen da sagte
scholz ja aber das sei doch schon
relativ flexibel jetzt als von der leyen
gefordert hat gedroht hat man müsste
russland mit weiteren
wirtschaftssanktionen belegen hat er
gesagt er wolle er dazu beitragen das zu
verhindern und beim streitthema atom wir
wollen die franzosen dass atomenergie
als so genannte grüne energie anerkannt
wird die grünen zu hause in deutschland
sind aber strikt dagegen und da hat
scholz einen bemerkenswerten satz gesagt
wir sind noch nicht beieinander aber
alle diskutieren wie das gelingen kann
also die erste reise keine erkennbaren
fehler aber auch keine ecken und kanten
sagt theo koll vielen dank nach brüssel
vom kanzler zur aussenministerin
annalena baerbock reist heute nach polen
kein einfacher besuch wenn man an die
situation der migranten an der polnische
belarussischen grenze denkt oder an den
dauerkonflikt polens mit der eu beim
thema rechtsstaatlichkeit
zuerst wurde peer bork vom präsidenten
duda empfang nach einem gespräch mit
ihrem amtskollegen rauch sagte sie die
freundschaft zwischen beiden ländern sei
tief und innerhalb der europäischen
union unbezahlbar beim thema
rechtsstaatlichkeit setzt baerbock trotz
differenzen auf eine gemeinsame lösung
das regieren hat also begonnen für die
ampel koalition und das zdf
politbarometer hat nachgefragt und alle
zahlen hat matthias fornoff im blick
hallo matthias haller genannt wie kommt
die ampelkoalition denn an die neuen die
werden sehr unterschiedlich bewertet von
zustimmung des skepsis ist alles dabei
fangen wir mit dem bundeskanzler an olaf
scholz wird seine sache eher gut machen
sagen 77 prozent der befragten auch die
anhänger der oppositionsparteien union
und linke sehen das mehrheitlich so nur
die anhänger der afg haben überwiegend
zweifel wir haben weiter gefragt nach
der besetzung von schlüsselministerien
durch spd fdp und grüne karl lauterbach
wird seine sache als gesundheitsminister
er gut machen das erwarten 78
68 prozent glauben dass von christian
lindner als finanzminister bei annalena
baerbock als außenministerin überwiegt
dagegen die skepsis
jetzt aber viel erfahren über die
einzelnen personen über die
protagonistinnen und protagonisten wie
sieht es denn aus mit der neuen
bundesregierung welche zustimmungswerte
bekommt in der sie bekommen tatsächlich
sogar noch mehr zustimmung als vor zwei
wochen eine recht deutliche mehrheit von
58 prozent findet die ampel gut 24
prozent finden sie schlecht und wenn am
nächsten sonntag schon wieder
bundestagswahl wäre wenn wir die spd
unverändert auf 28 prozent cdu/csu 21
prozent plus 2 grüne 17 fdp 12 hf g10
beide -1 linke 5 prozent
die ampel parteien hätten damit
weiterhin eine deutliche mehrheit dann
vielen dank matthias fornoff das war ja
nur ein kleiner ausschnitt und das
gesamte politbarometer das gibt es dann
heute abend ab 22 uhr im heute journal
und natürlich können sie sich das ganze
auch in der zdf- heute- app jetzt schon
anschauen können da alles noch mal
nachlesen und sich durch klicken die
liste mit den beliebtesten politikern
die sonntagsfrage und viele ergebnisse
mehr
hamburgs sicherheitsbehörden konnten
offenbar einen islamistischen anschlag
verhindern nach der verhaftung eines
deutsch marokkaners wurden in seiner
wohnung materialien zum bau einer bombe
gefunden der 20 jährige hatte im darknet
versucht waffen zu kaufen geriet dabei
aber an verdeckte ermittler auch der
vater des beschuldigten verkehrte schon
in islamistischen kreisen mehr von
martin ließen die hamburger
ermittlungsbehörden sind sich sicher sie
haben einen islamistischen
terroranschlag verhindert bereits ende
august war ein 20 jahre alter
deutsch-marokkaner bei einem fingierten
waffenkauf festgenommen worden der
beschuldigte abdulrahman c hat in diesem
sommer versucht eine scharfe
handfeuerwaffe sowie einer handgranate
zu erwerben bei der kontaktperson an die
er sich dazu gewandt hatte handelte es
sich jedoch um einen verdeckt
arbeitenden mitarbeiter einer
sicherheitsbehörde bei
hausdurchsuchungen von die ermittler
dann islamistische propaganda und
materialien zum bombenbau der vater des
20-jährigen ist für die polizei kein
unbekannter er war jahrelang in der
bereits 2010 geschlossenen
al-quds-moschee aktiv dort hat noch
attentäter des 11 september verkehrt der
vater des beschuldigten bewegte sich in
den 2000er jahren in der radikal
islamistischen szene hamburgs und es mit
diversen personen bekannt die bereits zu
der zeit mit politisch motivierten
straftaten aus dem bereich des
islamismus in erscheinung getreten sind
ziel und zeitpunkt eines anschlags gibt
es laut hamburger behörden bisher keine
erkenntnisse
wikileaks-gründer julian assange droht
nun doch die auslieferung in die usa
heute gab ein gericht in london dem
antrag der amerikaner statt assange
sitzt seit 2009 10 in großbritannien im
gefängnis ein früheres urteil hatte eine
auslieferung aus gesundheitlichen
gründen noch untersagt in den usa drohen
dem wikileaks-gründer wegen spionage bis
zu 175 jahre haft assange verlobte
kündigte berufung gegen die heutige
entscheidung an
sie kämpfen für meinungs- und
pressefreiheit und riskieren dafür ihr
leben dafür ist eine journalistin und
eines journalisten heute der
friedensnobelpreis
überreicht worden maria resser von den
philippinen und dimitrij muratow aus
russland sie haben den preis in oslo
persönlich entgegengenommen und damit
sind sie in diesem jahr die einzigen die
vor ort geehrt wurden und das ist ja
eine echte ausnahme in corona zeiten
heike große berichtet
eine schweigeminute für alle verfolgten
und ermordeten journalisten und
journalistinnen das war sein wunsch
heute der russische journalist mit
innovator und seine philippinische
kollegin maria riesch nahm die
auszeichnung im osloer rathaus entgegen
ihr einsatz für die meinungsfreiheit
brachte den friedensnobelpreis
dass der preis heute an journalisten
geht ist ein signal ein historischer
moment für das nobelpreiskomitee
journalismus ein grundpfeiler der
demokratie
maria besser arbeitete als journalistin
in den usa ging von neun jahren zurück
in ihrer heimat die philippinen gründete
dort den nachrichtendienst keppler maria
roser wird wegen ihrer arbeit behindert
verfolgt wurde mehrfach verhaftet und
verklagt mitri muratow chefredakteur der
russischen zeitung nowaja gaseta der
letzten freien zeitung in russland trotz
ermordeter kollegen und ständiger
drohungen weigert er sich diese
unabhängigkeit aufzugeben
der journalismus macht in russland harte
zeiten durch in den vergangenen monaten
wurden hunderte journalisten
menschenrechtsaktivisten und
nichtregierungsorganisationen als
agenten fremder mächte bezeichnet in
russland bedeutet dass nur eins
volksfeinde
maria roser und mitri murat oft teilen
sich ein preisgeld von mehr als 900
80.000 euro damit wollen sie den kampf
für die meinungsfreiheit in ihren
heimatländern weiterführen
so wir sind beim sport und einer dicken
überraschung im biathlon christi den
männern bei den frauen lief es im sprint
von hochfilzen österreich nicht ganz so
glatt vanessa hinz wurde als beste
deutsche zehnte für ihren teamkollegen
johannes kühn war es dagegen der
erfolgreichste weltcup tag seine
laufbahn mit einer phänomenalen
schlussrunde holt johannes kühn den
ersten weltcupsieg seiner karriere nach
zehn kilometern sprint in hochfilzen
steht der 30-jährige mit nur einem
fehlschuss und einer strafrunde
überraschend ganz oben auf dem podest
mit mehr als 14 sekunden rückstand und
ebenfalls einem fehlschuss wird martin
pansy lohmar aus schweden zweiter
fehlerfrei aber deutlich langsamer war
anton smolski aus belarus bereits beim
weltcup in östersund hatte johannes kühn
die olympia-norm geknackt ein perfekter
start in den winter
vier deutsche fußballvereine in der
europa league für dortmund leipzig geht
es nach dem aus in der königsklasse im
februar in der zwischenrunde weiter
frankfurt und leverkusen sind als
tabellen erste zum abschluss der
gruppenphase bereits im achtelfinale
bereits vorzeitig das viertelfinale der
champions league haben die
fußballerinnen des fc bayern münchen
erreicht dank des sieges von lyon gegen
lissabon und des eigenen triumphes gegen
die schwedinnen vom bk häcken
in göteborg geraten die münchnerinnen in
weiß in rückstand durch shane black
studios nach 36 minuten steht's 1 0 für
den bk häcken doch das beste team geht
nach schnellem ausgleich noch vor der
pause in führung durch jovan damjanovic
die später in der 55 minute noch auf 3 2
1 für münchen erhöht zum 5 1-endstand
trifft linette bärenstein kurz vor
schluss die bayern frauen stehen damit
vorzeitig in der champions league ko
runde der besten acht
magnus carlsen bleibt weltmeister im
schach in dubai besiegte der 31 jahre
alte norweger seinen russischen
herausforderer jahren nahm nacho nach
der elften von maximal 14 partien zum
ersten mal seit acht jahren stehen die
deutschen handballerinnen bei einer
weltmeisterschaft im viertelfinale den
einzug sicherte sich das team von
bundestrainer henk groener durch die top
vorstellung gegen asienmeister südkorea
mit 37 zu 28 beste werferin mit je acht
treffern kapitänin emily burg und alina
krise zum fünften sieg im fünften spiel
in spanien und sonntagabend dann geht es
gegen dänemark weiter vielleicht
klappt's mit dem gruppensieg dann danke
christin wir beide und sie daheim
erfahren zum schluss noch erleuchtung
das lichterfest von leon taucht die
französische metropole gerade in
wunderbar leuchtenden farben 30
lichtspiele lassen die fassaden der
altstadt scheinbar lebendig werden
merci marie leuchtet es über den dächern
der stadt der dank an die jungfrau maria
die der legende nach die stadt von der
pest befreite ja die geschichte dürfe
sich sehr gerne wiederholen mit blick
auf gerona sagen hier manche der
zahlreichen zuschauer und wir nicken da
gerne mit ja wetteraussichten gibt es
gleich im anschluss von özden terli das
heute journal gibt es heute um 22 uhr
mit marietta slomka dann an diesem
freitag von uns für sie einen
entspannten start in dieses
adventswochenende und gerne bis morgen
also einen schönen abend für sie
[Musik]
ein schoko lahmte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter während über
mitteleuropa temperaturen um die null
grad marke liegen ist es im westen
europas deutlich milder und von dort
kommt die milderung zu uns zum sonntag
sehen hier die farben sind eher gelblich
grünliches deutlich wärmer als diese
bläulichen die allmählich weg gedrängt
werden ja und in der nacht gibt es kaum
eine spur von milderung viele wolken im
süden teils regen und schnee und glätte
nach norden hin gibt es nebel und
teilweise klart es auf die temperaturen
liegen fast überall im frostbereich -
gerade im osten deutschlands über schnee
sogar noch etwas kälter milder im
südwesten bei zwei grad also frostfrei
dort morgen im tagesverlauf wird der
schnee im süden allmählich weniger
ansonsten in der mitte etwas
sonnenschein nach norden hin ist es
dicht bewölkt mit höchsten temperaturen
von minus 1 grad nach osten hier also
dauerfrost 7 grad im westen deutschlands
und die nächsten tage am sonntag kommt
regen von westen her auf der gefriert
teilweise auf den eisigen böden und das
bei 0 bis 10 grad am montag ist es etwas
milder bei drei bis elf grad ein schöner
abend